Let's go next to Heyden from Morgantown, West
Virginia.
Haden from Morgantown, West Virginia.
You were on.
What is on your mind?
Not much.
I just want to ask you some questions about
down ballot races.
Sure.
Yes.
So currently, like out of the United States.
Like, if you just like in no particular state,
what is it like?
What?
Down ballot races right now are you most interested
in.
Really?
For me, it's the ones that could flip the
Senate to Democrats.
So, you know, I mean, certainly as a starting
point, I'm looking at Susan Collins in Maine
who at who's facing serik?
A challenge from Sarah Gideon.
I'm looking at Martha McSally in Arizona,
who's facing a challenge from Mark Kelly,
the Thom Tillis Cal Cunningham race in North
Carolina, Steve Bullock in Montana, the Joni
Ernst race in Iowa's interesting Jamie Harrison
versus Lindsey Graham.
Cory Gardner looks like he's going to lose
in Colorado.
That's where my focus is.
Yeah.
Currently, at least in my state, where we
have a race between Shelley Moore Capital
and Polishing Swearingen, it's been pretty
interesting since I like in the state, like
we're not like we have a history of progressive
politics, although like it's been a while
since, like an actual, like progressive politician
has made it this far since like we have like
Joe Manchin as our current V.P.
And it's very interesting to see how this
happens.
Yeah, I'm interested now.
I am interested to see how that how how that
goes.
I think the implications of for the balance
of power are less significant, but an interesting
race nonetheless.
I almost had a pretty progressive person win
for our in our governor primary, but he made
it very close, although the polls came down
to is like about a two.
It was like a two percent difference.
It was very close.
Hayden, what's it like living in West Virginia?
I never had the pleasure of visiting the state.
And, you know, you hear a lot of different
things.
What what what's the experience like I in
the States?
It's actually pretty interesting since people
usually assume it's just like backwoods hillbilly
areas.
Right.
Although like in which in all fairness, a
lot of the state is like that, although there
are two main cities like Morgantown where
I live.
It's like a college towns like pretty vibrant.
And there's also Charleston, which is a very
nice city.
Sadly, like our population numbers are going
down pretty significantly throughout most
of the state.
I believe we're like the fastest shrinking
states, although we do have a few towns which
are growing, which is nice.
So like in Morgantown, for example, would
you be able to go to a are there like pretentious
third wave coffee shops and stuff?
Oh yeah.
There are some interesting coffee shops.
I don't want to like there's actually one
like Rosett because to me, like the terror
cafe, like there by the water, it's like since
there's college students, it's like it's like
a bit more of like a younger audience for
those bright areas.
But like in the like Charleston also as some
like more like Semien, like hipster, he like
shops and stuff, although overall it's like,
like the population is generally older and
the state's got like younger people tend to
go to other areas.
All right.
Well it sounds like you're doing okay there
then.
Yeah.
All right.
Hayden, appreciate hearing from you.
Hope to hear
from
you again.
Yeah.
Thank
you for
your time, David.
All right.
There is Heyden from West Virginia